hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 15 video finally
learned the identity of the reverse
flash also got to meet the new weather
wizard don't feel bad if your reverse
flash theory didn't pan out the way they
adapted the comics is a little confusing
because they're blending the Wally West
run and the Barry Allen run so you have
aspects of two different reverse flashes
combined I still do think we're gonna
see another reverse flash before the end
of the season now that we know who he is
though we can talk about which
storylines they might do because they
said that they're building up to a very
notable flash story probably having to
do with this guy here so just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet starting with top five
moments number five meet the new weather
wizard I like the way they started the
episode in flashback we go like all the
way back to the first episode in the
particle accelerator explosion we see
that both Mardon brothers were on that
plane when it exploded I chuckled a
little bit when Martin said that he
broke every bone in his body I mean I
mean that sucks I mean obviously that's
gonna hurt a lot but he was just laid up
this entire time that's why we didn't
see him until now is because all of his
bones were broken a lot of you guys were
tweeting last airbender jokes at me
during the episode like korra last
airbender like he is the avatar of the
flash universe avatar the last flash
bender because Liam McIntyre is such an
amazing actor there plug and try and
keep him around as long as possible so
however they wrap him up however they
defeat him in next week's episode the
pride do so in a way that will allow him
to come back it's just that the flash
show has been losing actors to this new
spin-off show like we've already lost
captain cold and heat wave heat wave was
just signed to the new spin-off show
meaning there you have to bring in some
new rogues so it's like mirror master
and obviously the new weather wizard I
say it all the time but I totally dig
the special effects that they used for
him and the fact that they gave Barry
Allen a full-blown lightsaber to defeat
him it was really a twist on the weather
control rod that the classic weather
wizard used I explained it in my trailer
video but the original weather wizard
wasn't called weather wizard Clyde
Mardon was a scientist he was a weather
scientist that created the control rod
to help people his brother mark Mardon
was a villain
he stole the rod killed his brother
accidentally and then took the mantle of
weather wizard and used the device to
commit crime so the show just had a nice
twist on that they they give him special
powers and they gave Barry Allen the
control rod the ball is now in your
court Stephen Amell it's like
Grant Gustin just wanted to get in on
the lightsaber Saturday fun time number
four the Barry Irish ship starts to
cause some waves describe all the big
WTF s in the episode using weather puns
that's the challenge
so Barry and iris started to take off
there had been some clips of them
kissing on the set previously but they
were kind of spoilery so I just chose to
avoid them I'm really bummed this is
gonna make his relationship with Linda
Park go down in flames because she's
just an amazing character I really hope
the show keeps her on in season two but
now the iris is finally in on the secret
she can start having some fun too but
the character is gonna get so much more
fun now there's nothing worse than being
like the one odd character out like the
one who doesn't know what's going on at
all it just it makes you look kind of
silly as we saw in the teaser for the
next episode obviously this is gonna
have a very bad effect on Barry's
relationship with Eddie Thawne there's a
whole lot of Eddie Thawne to talk about
especially with respect to the
reverse-flash so I'm gonna wade through
that as we get through WTF just because
there's so much stuff to get through on
to number three Mason bridge has
evidence that Harrison wells killed
Simon Stagg as we saw in the trailer
he's going to be getting a visit from
the reverse-flash pretty soon probably
to get the information on that digital
drive but because things got a little
tiny why me at the end of the episode it
throws a lot of the timeline into
question he said he was going to publish
the information on Sunday and it's
usually Tuesday like it's usually
Tuesdays whenever the show airs it just
is funny that way
so if Barry went back in time it means
that next week's episode will also be on
the same Tuesday so the reverse-flash
will have to go after him before Sunday
so that'll also probably happen in next
week's episode we also saw footage in
the trailer that looked like it was from
episode 18 the crossover episode where
they were investigating a dead body it's
possible that that dead body is either
Simon Staggs or it's Harrison wells I
know a lot of you think that it might be
like Harrison wells in the reverse-flash
just assumed his identity when he killed
him in the past or Harrison wells could
be a completely fictional persona like
he could have never existed based on
what Mason Bridger said I'm gonna guess
that the corpse belongs to Simon Stagg
on to number two
Barry accidentally time-travels while
trying to defeat weather wizard this is
our first look at time travel it didn't
look like Barry had to get too crazy I
mean he was screaming while he was
running so clearly he was going super
fast but what I really want to know now
is is how is he going to learn to
control time travel
because this time it was a total
accident like maybe he needs to expend
more speed energy to go further
backwards and forwards in time and how
does he control whether or not he goes
backwards or forwards it seems like part
of the next week's episode is gonna have
to be like a part two because he's gonna
be reliving some of these events
that explains why cisco is still alive
in the trailer remember Barry does not
know that Cisco was killed and he
doesn't know that Harrison wells is a Oh
Bart Thawne but the producers said that
when he time travelled for the first
time it was gonna be like a ground hogs
day funny Terminator scary situation
like funny and scary at the same time so
expect him to do things just a little
bit differently the second time around
like he's probably gonna try and track
down whether wizard extra-fast and that
will lead to him consequently getting to
Cisco before he gets killed and finally
my number one WTF moment easy here
Harrison wells reveals himself as a
Abarth on the reverse-flash some would
say I am the reverse such a great reply
the best reveal on the show so far from
start to finish the man in the yellow
suit they saw was a recording that's
what Cisco was watching just a recording
on a loop so when he was punching
Harrison wells it was just Harrison
wells mimicking being punched I think
I've explained the back story of a
Abarth on in like at least three or four
videos recently so I'll try to find a
link and I'll add one in the description
but basically he's from the 25th century
everything is super boring there aren't
any accidents and it drives him crazy
eventually he learns about the flash
studies him gains flash powers Barry
Allen ends up fighting him so they
become enemies so he starts to
time-travel to try and defeat the flash
but because he needs Barry Allen to
become the flash first he can't kill
Barry Allen that's where he even to
flashpoint paradox
I don't know necessarily that the show
is gonna try that they might just try
for the storyline where Barry snaps his
neck just to explain both those
storylines flashpoint paradox I mean
they turned it into an animated movie
that you may have seen to the
reverse-flash tries to turn Barry Allen
into a living paradox so that he can
kill him but still retain his reverse
flash powers during the Silver Age
comics the Barry Allen flash snapped
professor zooms neck ao Barton's neck
when he tried to kill iris West
so the show could be building towards
like one of those two big storylines
flashpoint paradox
way bigger deal than snapping the
reverse flashes Nick and I really do not
want Tom Cavanagh to leave the show I
totally want him back for season two
time travel changing the past is a way
to accomplish that think about it this
way Barry went back in time so he's
gonna do things a little bit differently
Cisco won't die so he's already changed
the past meaning that they can continue
to do that they can keep going back and
back in time the other option is is that
Barry kills a Bart Thawne at the end of
the season but someone else takes the
mantle of the reverse-flash obviously
talking about Eddie Thawne that gets
into another Wally West storyline where
they transition from professor zoom to
zoom it involves a gorilla grodd attack
and Gorilla Grodd is in an upcoming
episode we see Eddie Thawne killing two
cops so him taking the man solo the
reverse-flash before the end of the
season could have something to do with
the garage storyline so that's really
good jumping-off point what is the big
storyline from the comics that you think
that they're building towards is very
gonna snap a bar dawn's neck or is it
going to be even bigger it's gonna be
like flashpoint paradox it can also be
just as simple as transitioning from a
bar Thawne to the hunter zolomon zoom
like they could lock up eobard thawne in
the metahuman prison but after that
Eddie Thawne could visit him and learn
about the future of his family and gain
reverse flash powers that way so I've
already mentioned most of the Easter
eggs in the episode just is through my
top 5 WTF moments but here are a couple
really important comic book storylines
you guys should check out that are
relevant to what's going on right now
there's a prequel comic to flashpoint
paradox that explains a bard Dawn's
backstory I've also made a video based
on that so I had a link in the
description there's the once and future
flash that's a Wally West versus a Oh
Bart thawne's story where a Oh Bart
Thawne also explains his backstory it's
really cool too because it's the reverse
flash masquerading as Barry Allen versus
Wally West and then you should read
flash number 324 that's the issue where
Barry Allen snaps his neck I know a lot
of you are asking what's going on
between Eddie Thawne and air Bart on
what's the connection Eddie Thawne is
probably just his great great you know
many times removed grandfather the
Thawne line has a long-standing rivalry
with the Allen family with the flash
family some of what happens in the next
couple of episodes is going to set that
so as we can see stealing his girlfriend
not a good way to go that's gonna start
things off it's gonna get worse than
there it's only gonna get worse as we
get towards the finale a rift will
develop between Eddie and Barry until
something really bad happens we could
see the gorilla grodd accident happen
the hunter zolomon accident from the
comics that could be the breaking point
where Eddie Thawne looks to become a
reverse flash thus beginning the lawn
fawn heritage that being said just
because Eddie Thawne is going to wind up
hating Barry on hating the flash it
doesn't mean that a Oh Bart Thawne also
hates the flash for the same reason he's
a mad genius from the future he can do
whatever he wants he can time travel why
would he continue to hate the flash
unless the flash has been battling him
specifically typically in the comics
it's been a lot simpler than that
eobard thawne has just been crazy and
hated the flash he wanted to steal his
powers from him what's probably happened
is is in the future he's had some crazy
plan the flash stopped him so he's
trying to kill the flash in the past so
that he can't stop him in the future
yay for time travel I am very much
definitely doing a Q&A for this episode
this week but I'm wait till after the
arrow episode so be sure to subscribe to
get that don't forget new episode of
arrow tomorrow they're gonna explain
Rachele ghouls off we're gonna learn a
lot more about the history of the League
of Assassins so while you guys wait for
that you can click here for the flash
trailer again especially for you know
for footage for the next couple of
episodes and you can click here for my
arrow trailer thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
everybody let's do the thing and go back
in time
you